hello and welcome to this video playing
best of three yeah probably not in a
best-of-three match but just the one
game yeah let's see what we got
I got coffee that's good gotta close
Spanish him yeah I'd like to do
something else then my Walter Bishop
oh sorry 95 cheering yeah okay let's
play the Bram before is a bit uncommon
but that's kind of it to become remove
just that now that if I was hanging
maybe he has to yeah do this or Bishop
see to what that doesn't really work
well together okay a question that is
always tough for me to answer is should
I play c5 in such a position or be
flexible about it you know I don't know
I don't really have to make this
decision now hmm yeah Queen I think with
the Queen it's a bit off when a a turn
doesn't really do much for center you
know I mean this must be quite okay for
me
miyaji six Bishop d7 is oftentimes a
good way of regrouping the Bishop on g7
gives some protection to e5 so that d5
is more of them possibility okay so
let's prepare maybe c6 and t5 yeah he's
got Knight f5 I don't think it's a huge
problem
now g5 a good g5 that was the idea also
I could go night c5 in 96 that could be
a way to improve the peace placement a
little bit yeah maybe I is taking a
while it's not that not that easy to
find a plan for white either you don't
really have an easy way to play deform
me sorry I can't go Bishop c2 and you
can prepare it and probably make it at
the end but you cannot play d4
right in this particular moment and the
knight jumps how small this time user to
success of maybe disconnected or
anything did I disconnect does it feel
like it
all right that's odd
[Music]
yeah I guess they're the technical issue
now he plays a move okay and I wasn't
really expecting that to happen anymore
I didn't know if I should really yeah
release that as a video probably rather
not
okay so dark squares no g6 is my idea
winning a piece okay yeah neighbor from
I thought you would probably take only
seven and then play a form I will get to
a four at the end yeah this is the thing
that concerns me a little bit that he
gets this in but I felt Queen g5 should
be fine Queen g5 yeah let's do it
g5 Queen g4 should win and now I mean g6
doesn't really help not threatening to
take because of this G file situation
okay
yeah that's mater that's made okay I
didn't that didn't put up much
resistance that was very odd that he
took that much time
yeah maybe I so really that I don't know
okay we had done fairly normal position
him yeah I know I'm not sure that c6 is
strictly necessary but playing C's 65 is
a long-term goal that black has the
engine also points out less immediate
maneuver to e6 yeah the night is not too
bad here only six can sometimes go here
I mean as you see it this is rather
symmetric I if you look at this part of
the board no it is somewhat symmetrical
we have differences of course with the
with the bishops but pure porn structure
wise it's it's very symmetrical may jump
to f5 preparing I prevented ninety five
and now this and I don't think that is
really that great here 96 is supposed to
give white an advantage that is hard to
believe why is that so good
um I mean if I take I really wonder what
the what the thing what the point is why
is that such a problem
I'm absolutely I'm willing to accept
that this is not an equal position and
why does a bit better but why is it 0.8
I mean that line yeah maybe it's just
this concrete line that's the problem
that night if eight green before is an
issue doubt that is it really such an
issue so let's say the engine gives B
should be seven okay definitely I need
to get this three six or somewhere else
okay then the engine wants to take okay
rook takes Queen two before yeah I see
that it is a bit annoying but still
fully there early in the name of 98 and
deform yeah white has an initiative
that's definitely true yeah that's
across time yeah I mean it's not it's
not the most obvious concept at least to
me that white would give up his
seemingly best piece on b3 and then take
take this odd-looking piece but you get
this concrete idea and with Queen before
and then yeah white is a tad better know
for me I'm moving the bishop away I
wasn't quite sure way out him but was
rather automatic k-96 yeah G for his
Audion that weakens becomes a lot yes he
have of course you can play c5 but I
wanted to go on the dark squares like
to Bishop e7 which is debatable I
thought I thought after Bishop d7 he
might just take or h4 actually okay mmmh
for as possible yeah it's difficult it's
difficult now here for me to untangle I
cannot go g6 of course him okay now I'm
fine again at least okay lets him he had
starts to get better for black
hmm taking with a pawn right it's not
it's it's not bad yeah yeah I get g6 in
I get g6 in quicker the nightmare force
a bit too tempting but this doesn't seem
to be all that all that clear that's
remarkable here by the way this why can
I not take because of 90 xg4 ah and 90
xh6
let's it's sick yeah that's sick so I'm
not threatening to take on g4 which
makes Queen g5 kind of pointless huh
okay they have to go f6 then yeah here
my position is a lot better because I
get to see aid and then ultimately
threaten to take which should make white
yeah basically fall apart okay it
doesn't have to play ninety six and give
me the maid but it's a pretty awful
position already okay guys thanks for
watching